L'épisode final de sense8 sort
Aujourd'hui mais juste avant d'aller le regarder je vous propose qu'on s'attarde sur cinq points qui vont peut-être vous faire regarder la série autrement
après l'intro bien sûr
Et salut à tous les amis c'est François pour la chaîne explique moi encore. Ça me fait extrêmement plaisir de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
vidéo et aujourd'hui on va s'attaquer à une nouvelle série, j'ai nommé Sense8
alors si comme moi vous êtes super excités à l'idée de connaître enfin la fin de la série cette vidéo risque de vous plaire.
Parce que Sense8 c'est
prenant, c'est addictif mais c'est surtout très très très très beau alors aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous parler de cinq trucs
qui vont peut-être même vous faire aimer la série encore plus. Alors ce qu'il faut savoir avant toute chose c'est qu'aux manettes de la
série on a les soeurs Wachowski à qui on doit notamment la trilogie Matrix Cloud Atlas, Speed Racer et le scénario de V pour vendetta
autrement dit il ya déjà du level. Et chez soeurs Wachowski dans chaque projet qu'elle mènent, y a des putain de choix
artistiques de malades. Même si de prime abord on dirait pas comme ça et avec Sense8 elles se sont embarquées dans un chantier complètement
titanesque et ultra rigoureux. Mais bon allez je vous fais pas attendre plus attaquons nous directement au premier point je veux bien sûr parler des décors.
Alors je vous refais pas le pitch hein mais Sense8 c'est une série qui se passe un peu partout sur la planète
et dans un souci de réalisme et bah, de
grandiose tout simplement les soeurs Wachowski ont décidé de tourner les scènes dans les vrais lieux où elles se trouvent
autrement dit là où on a souvent des décors créés sur fond vert par ordinateurs etc
là que dalle
c'est du vrai, vrai de vrai et ça se voit et par conséquent le tournage a eu lieu dans une bonne dizaine de villes et
tout autant de pays à tel point qu'on a les mêmes des équipes de tournage
dédié par lieu, par pays, par ville genre Chicago, San Francisco, Reykjavík, Berlin, Londres, Nairobi
enfin
voilà truc de malade quoi
et pour la petite histoire il ya une scène de course poursuite qui se déroule à Nairobi qui a nécessité la bagatelle
de 700 figurants, 200 voitures et un hélicoptère, et c'est déjà en ça que la série elle est dingue visuellement
c'est que on a pas de triche on a des vrais décors on n'a pas de fond vert on n'a pas d'artifices
on est dans le vrai et les soeurs Wachoski sont allées chercher des décors grandioses
mais des décors réels
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que la série a failli ne pas avoir de fin, budget de
malade. Mais heureusement les fans se sont mobilisés pour qu'on ait un épisode final et ça c'est cool. Deuxième point qui va nous intéresser aujourd'hui
c'est ce que j'appellerais le slow mo mais le slow mo quand il le faut
alors c'est pas nouveau déjà depuis matrix avec les soeurs Wachoski, on avait des plans au ralenti assez
épique et bha là en sense8, on a aussi des superbes plans en slow motion mais qui sont faits avec beaucoup de goût
le slow motion oui c'est beau c'est sympa c'est super cinématique mais quand on le met un petit peu partout sans raison
bah on perd en efficacité on perd en impact sur le spectateur là le slow motion on le retrouve dans des moments vraiment
spécifiques c'est à dire qu'on va avoir du slow motion pour des scènes d'action notamment qui vont les rendre encore plus
dramatique mais on a aussi un effet hypnotique notamment quand on a bha nos huits personnages qui font des trucs
qui peuvent interdits aux moins de 18 ans et qui retranscrit un petit peu l' espèce de transe dans lesquelles ils sont
donc on a vraiment du slow motion et de la technique au service d'un scénario et ça c'est vraiment cool merci pour ça les soeurs
Wachoski! Ah oui et le slow motion
si vous savez pas comment ça marche, tout simplement on va filmer à plus de 24 images par seconde pour pouvoir avoir
pleins d'images par seconde, les étirer et avoir un ralenti qui va être fluide, 24 images par seconde c'est le format standard que vous avez
dans toutes les séries et les films américains. Et vous pouvez le faire aussi chez vous avec votre smartphone à une
bien plus petite échelle hein bien sûr en réglant les images par seconde à 60, 120 ou 240
allez on enchaîne troisième point qui fait que la série est visuellement super impactante je vais vous parler des couleurs
bon ok la série elle est filmée avec une caméra 4k sony de ouf qui est juste énormissime
mais là où sense8 se démarque encore c'est par ses couleurs ou plutôt sa colorimétrie
si vous faites attention dans beaucoup de séries, beaucoup de films on a une colorimétrie qui tourne toujours autour des tons orange et cyan le fameux
teal and orange qui est utilisé un petit peu partout et depuis
super longtemps il y en a qui disent que c'est un effet de mode mais c'est super vieux le teal and orange hein ça
oula... Mais dans sense8 on a vraiment une palette de couleurs
super étendue on n'est pas vraiment
cantonné à ces deux couleurs là on a des choses qui sont très flashy des couleurs
très pop et c'est pas sans rappeler le film spider racer, sorti en 2008 par les soeurs Wachoski toujours
dans lequel les personnages évoluent dans un univers ultra coloré limite cartoonesque
ben là encore une fois on a quelque chose en plus de ces décors qui sont
grandioses est magnifiques, on a un traitement des couleurs
qui les met en valeur et qui va refléter toutes les couleurs réelles de ces lieux qui sont pour le moins assez
fantastiques, donc pour la couleur sense8 encore une fois carton plein
mais que serait la couleur sans le point que nous allons évoquer tout de suite c'est à dire la lumière
alors on vous l'a certainement dit, ne fait pas de photos ou de vidéos en contre jour c'est moche on va rien voir
ben je vous laisse juger par vous même voilà le contre jour c'est pas forcément une mauvaise chose alors nous à notre petit niveau
avec notre matériel on va peut-être pas forcément à voir autre chose qu'une silhouette noire avec un fond qui va être exposé correctement, même si
on va pouvoir rattraper des choses en post production sur notre logiciel de montage
mais si on distingue beaucoup plus de détails tout simplement parce que la caméra utilisée a ce qu'on appelle une grande plage dynamique c'est-à-dire qu'à
une exposition donnée elle va arriver à capter des détails dans les tons sombres sans avoir des noirs qui vont être complètement
dégueulasses et écrasés et aussi en même temps dans les tons clairs sans avoir des blancs qui vont être complètement cramé. Et les soeurs Wachoski
elles aiment bien jouer avec la lumière du soleil, avec le contre jour avec ces petits rayons chaleureux, voire même avec des
artefacts qu'on appelle des flairs qui vont être des
réflexions qui vont être faites sur la lentille utilisé pour la caméra, alors pareil toujours petite astuce si nous on veut gagner en plage dynamique
et qu'on n'a pas une caméra de ouf, on va aussi pouvoir filmer en flat ou en log
je vous en parle d'ailleurs dans la vidéo qui s'affiche ici sur laquelle vous pouvez
cliquer on va arriver avec ses réglages à récupérer un petit peu plus de plage dynamique que si on utilisait un mode standard et puis
en termes de lumière on le dira jamais assez mais la golden hour
c'est le graal de tous les vidéastes ou les photographes et c'est un truc tout bête qui marche à tous les coups la golden hour
ça consiste à filmer à un moment précis de la journée
c'est à dire grosso modo une demi heure avant et après le lever et le coucher du soleil
et c'est le moment de la journée où on aura la lumière
la plus douce la plus flatteuse et les couleurs les plus jolies et donc pas
réciproque le moment le moins adapté pour filmer dans la journée tout simplement c'est midi c'est quand le soleil est le plus haut dans le
ciel, on préférera avoir un soleil qui est bas le matin très tôt ou le soir
juste avant la nuit
et d'ailleurs il ya même des as pour les gens un petit peu feignant comme moi pour savoir exactement quand se situe la golden hour
je vous en met quelques unes dans la description
donc voilà la lumière c'est assez flagrant quand vous regarderez sense8, elle est utilisée de façon très intelligente au moment du tournage
enfin le dernier point que je voulais aborder avec vous qui est un point essentiel
selon moi dans ce sens'e8, c'est la sobriété des effets spéciaux
Alors cette série elle aurait pu se prêter à des effets visuels en 3d
à l'appel, elle aurait pu se prêter voilà comme c'est du fantastique à des choses assez
assez folle et finalement on se rend compte qu'on a quelque chose de très organique
déjà on en parlait au niveau des décors hein on est sur du vrai décor et là encore
ben on a très peu d'effets spéciaux rajouté en post production si ce n'est les explosions etc
et très souvent les éléments un peu fantastiques de la série bha sont retranscrits par des mouvements de caméra ou par des choses très très
simples, je vous prends un exemple les personnages peuvent switcher
les uns dans le corps des autres et on aurait pu avoir ici un espèce de morphing dégueulasse ou des choses qui seraient
très retravailler en post production mais non les soeurs Wachoski, elles, elles ont décidé de retranscrire ça tout simplement par des cut,
par des transitions qui sont même pas des transitions
logicielles ce sont des transitions manuelles comme ici par exemple où on voit
un personnage passer et hop un petit faux mouvement et hop le personnage qui a changé
derrière ça c'est pas fait du tout en post production s'est fait à la main avec la caméra tout simplement
et ça c'est très fort et ça donne une cohérence en fait où tout où on a vraiment une
réalisation qui va être à mon sens très organique qui va pas être quelque chose de très
travaillée par ordinateur et ça amène quelque chose de très humain qui va donner un aspect réaliste
presque plausible à la série tout ça parce qu'on n'a pas fait trop de choses en post-production tout ça parce qu'on n'a pas mis trop
d'effets spéciaux trop de 3d trop d'after effects bon et peut-être aussi est franchement j'espère pas mais que le budget pharaonique
qui a été englouti dans la série bha laisser plus trop de place aux effets spéciaux
rien que pour ça quand même merci les soeurs Wachoski, ça fait du bien d'avoir une série fantastique
sans avoir trois tonnes d'effets en 3d rajouter en plus. Et voilà les amis on a fait le tour un petit peu de ce que
je voulais vous dire sur cette série si les cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à mettre un coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo pensez à vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
et puis comme toujours bien entendu rester curieux et moi je vous dis à très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
Il